desde el anuncio del presidente de Rusia
Vladimir Putin sobre la movilización de
reservistas a la Guerra de Ucrania miles
de rusos se van a países vecinos a
Georgia cruzan casi 10.000 rusos
diariamente
uno de los puntos fronterizos se
encuentra aquí en kaspegui donde se
presentan los primeros brotes de
xenofobia estos manifestantes con
pancartas en las que se lee Rusia es un
ocupante y Putin terrorista se oponen a
la entrada masiva de rusos mijail es un
activista ucraniano residente en Georgia
está ocupada por Rusia así como una
parte de Ucrania también está ocupada
por ellos por eso los rusos no son
bienvenidos aquí ni visto como amigos o
hermanos
[Música]
tamar es una mujer georgiana
perteneciente a un partido político por
occidental se queja a las autoridades
fronterizas
esta manifestación Busca demostrar la
voluntad del pueblo georgiano desterrar
la frontera desde que Rusia declaró la
movilización muchos ciudadanos rusos han
venido a nuestra frontera queremos que
los rusos sepan que no son bienvenidos
un descontento por parte de algunos
georgianos que se basa en heridas del
pasado
aquí el conflicto ucraniano Parece ser
un déjà Vu de lo sucedido en 2008 cuando
la región separatista de osetia del sur
apoyada por Rusia se enfrentó
militarmente al ejército georgiano
tropas del kremlin alcanzaron a entrar
en la capital del Pequeño país ex
soviético tiflis
14 años después los ciudadanos
provenientes del país Invasor intentan
refugiarse de la guerra en Ucrania que
para muchos de los rusos es fratricida